selon pascal emond photos persos juste
après dans la rue la route pour koné
excellant dans le polar pour une fois
est vraiment cool j call you lie
excellent vraiment alors je reste un
petit peu en retrait c'est un grand
moment vous allez vivre derrière moi
tout le temps board de mettre là c'est
peut-être mieux on pascalou le concert
symphonique billets de faim à les six
mois je vous laisse tous les deux non
mais je veux lui faire je vais aller
selon bbc
oui oui c'est bien mais il ont jamais
transformé lui sur mathieu jeu ça va
faire plaisir ludique
mathieu bas
mathieu c'est moi tu sais il ya des
soirs comme ça où tout
s'écroule autour de nous
sans trop savoir pourquoi toujours
regardez devant soir
n'ont jamais baissé les bras je sais je
suis pas le remède à tous
mais faut savoir c'est parfois mathieu
mathieu dépêche toi on vit
on ne meurt qu'une fois
mais on a tout de rien
que c'est déjà la fin mais c'est pas
marqué dans les livres
le plus important à vivre c'est de vivre
au jour le jour
autant cette année
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus important un livre c'est le niveau
au jour le jour
le temps
[Musique]
c'est de l'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci pascal m'a sauvé c'est bocal south
et apportera toute la france parce
qu'elle est forte